[Music]
using
a uv lamp to kill the coronavirus that's
just one light bulb moment in a
multitude of responses to covet 19.
cologne was repurposed as hand sanitizer
at the beginning of the pandemic
the speed of innovation amid coronavirus
could be a game changer
experts say it could revolutionize
global health care
allowing us to come up with solutions
that could change health
care delivery
[Music]
they say necessity is the mother of
invention
the coronavirus pandemic has thrown that
into stark relief
from innovations enabling us to live
with the realities of the virus
to devices that make its detection
possible
here's the story of two entrepreneurs
who say a diagnosis
is just a breath away brothers jan
kristoff and thomas wolfe have a vision
they want to return some normality to
this covered 19 times
for months they've been working on a
breath test that can identify the
novocorona virus
they are now confident it
from a works point of view this device
can get to areas where normally only a
dog can sniff things out
a device that's almost as sensitive as a
dog's nose
the technique is similar to a breath
analyzer for alcohol
what we have here is a sterile
mouthpiece
you take off the packaging and then what
happens
you blow into the mouthpiece you just
breathe
in their startup the brothers develop
highly sensitive sensor technology for
mass spectrometers
for industry and labs for a new type of
diagnosis in real time economics
we can see all sorts of things using
breath analysis like whether a patient
had coffee yesterday afternoon or not
we can identify his nutritional status
we can see different amino acids
different fatty acids all of this from
the breath
breath is a direct window into the human
body
the brothers believe it could recognize
carbon 19. other researchers also say
breath analysis could work in principle
to test for the corona virus
the challenge is to is to get the
methods that you run on the equipment
the way the equipment is used the tune
and the analytical technique optimized
with verified biomarkers that
are reliable once we've proven that
then you have a coveted 19 breath test
ready to go
conventional swept tests are reliable
but often only carried out when the
infection has been there for a while and
a result usually takes
two days the breath test detects
metabolic changes in breathing caused by
the virus
while it is not yet 100 reliable it does
give an immediate result
the researchers believe that they will
be able to deploy the tests as early as
next summer
in places like football stadiums
passengers could also be tested at
airports before check-in
the accuracy of the test is currently
around 80 percent however the
researchers are expecting efficiency to
increase significantly
in the meantime a lot of detailed work
remains to be done
people are complicated and you're
looking for a small signal
in a snowstorm a blizzard of information
um
but but we've we've found we've found
the signals we think are helpful jan
kristoff and thomas wolfe originally
developed their tests for very different
types of diagnosis one problem with a
covid19 test is that they have not yet
been able to carry out studies on
patients with a virus
they are hoping for access to the
processes
access to resources to allow us to carry
out a validation study
on site in a hospital orton airport test
center
and with that it becomes very easy to
determine whether this would be a way to
bring back some normality to people
breath analyzers could be a way to
detect carbon-19 infections much
faster than before
matthew harris joins us now he's a
clinical senior lecturer in public
health at the imperial college london
matthew so glad you can join us now
you've written
in the scientific journal nature about
how the response to covid19 has been
distinguished by so-called
frugal innovations what exactly does
that mean
well thank you frugal innovation really
is the term that we give
to the kind of innovation we see under
resource constraints or
situations of extraordinary time
pressure or
situations where we don't have the kind
of resources that we normally like to
have when we
when we develop healthcare innovations
the word frugal
oftentimes is referred to as sort of
cheap or good enough
innovation but actually frugal
innovation is is
healthcare innovation that's actually as
effective as the kind of innovation we
would normally see
but just done in a way that is far more
affordable far more sustainable
maybe with fewer sort of complexity or
functionality but that gets the job
done and under covid of course we've
seen around the world some
extraordinarily difficult
uh situations at national level in terms
of exposing the fragilities in our
healthcare systems but also
the real increase in healthcare demand
and it really has necessitated a new
type of innovating um
innovating at pace uh rapidly
um using resources that we just find
around us
uh so kind of improvising if you like uh
and this is the
the kind of innovation that we call
frugal innovation
so it's about reacting quickly using
what you have but do you have any
examples of what
a frugal innovation could be
well absolutely in the early days of the
covid response we saw in
several developing countries some really
interesting examples of frugal
innovations so for example where there
was a lack of personal protective
equipment
we saw clinicians improvise the use of
simple acetate sheets the kind of
acetate sheets that you'd use for
overhead projectors
in the old days and by simply
putting some holes in either side of the
acetate sheet and threading some ribbon
on either side
those became very effective face visors
to protect not only the clinician but
also the patients in front of them
when they were intubating and this was
of course extremely cheap and actually
very very effective
since then face visors have evolved and
become
more sophisticated but it was a very
good example of a frugal innovation at
the time
another good example of innovating at
pace
was the construction of hospitals in
under 10 days in china
and actually eventually also in the uk
where i'm from we saw the construction
or repurposing at least of conference
centers into into
intensive care units and hospitals also
in very very short amounts of time so
this sort of idea of repurposing the
resources you have
but also very very quickly the
characteristic of frugal innovation
now that the crisis has focused minds
and mobilized so much in terms of
responses
as you've told us there is there also
kind of
downside to this kind of concentration
of response the crisis
well i think the covet obviously has
required a deviation of resources from
other areas of healthcare
to focus our attention on the covert
response and as a result
some out there areas have have if you
like suffered
in terms of research going into them and
also the healthcare delivery
for different clinical conditions um i
don't think there's a downside to frugal
innovation
um i think it's been a really revealing
how we've been able to
develop such effective healthcare
responses in a short
period of time and without scrimping
on safety checks or effectiveness or
clinical effectiveness for
for the patients that we serve so i
don't see a downside of frugal
innovation which tends to be far more
affordable for healthcare systems
as long as the necessary checks and
balances are in place to ensure
safety of those devices or technologies
you've written that this kind of
innovation
could lead to a leveling in global
healthcare equality
what does that look like
well it's a leveler in the sense that
covet has made us really reflect on the
fragilities in the health systems
even in high-income country settings and
it's made us pay much more attention to
the kind of innovations that arise from
low-income countries
it's something we've been advocating for
for many years and what covert is doing
is making us pay
therefore more attention to settings
that traditionally we haven't really
noticed in terms of healthcare
innovation
thank you matthew harris they're talking
about putting human resourcefulness at
the center of our covet 19 response he's
a clinical senior lecturer in public
health at the imperial college london
thank you for your insights and now it's
time for one of your sent in questions
about the coronavirus
our science correspondent derek williams
is ready with an answer
taking into account a patient's sex and
age what do the statistics say about
complications
one of the clearest pieces of
information that's come out of the
statistics is that from the age of about
40 on women in general
are a lot less likely than men to have
severe
outcomes data from both the cdc
and the european center for disease
prevention and control
reveal how stark the difference is
this graphic for example emphasizes how
much more
likely men of a certain age are
to end up in the hospital or the icu
numbers of men are represented by the
blue bar and
numbers of women by the red one in
europe
men between 40 and 80 make up around
three quarters of all
intensive care cases and recorded deaths
after 80 the split is more even but
that's almost
certainly due to the simple fact that a
lot fewer men
lived at that age so statistically the
chances are a lot higher that in the
over 80s
a woman is going to get covered 19 then
a man is going to get it
there's a lot of speculation about why
and there doesn't seem to be a single
reason that accounts for all of the
discrepancy um several factors are
likely playing roles
we know though that that people who have
diabetes or high blood pressure
or heart disease are at greater risk
of severe outcomes if they contract
covid19
and and aging men are more likely to
have
those comorbidities than aging women are
but another possible contributing factor
involves
immune response the male and female
immune systems are different
experts say because on their second x
chromosome
women have another copy of many of the
genes that are involved
in fighting off disease it's been
theorized that's also
why women are more likely to develop
certain autoimmune diseases than men
but in this case it could be helping
them keep covet 19
or its medical ramifications more
effectively at bay
that's hard to prove though
you